[Musique]
ils sont quatorze candidats tous
finalistes du concours du challenge des
créateurs le jury récompensera tous les
participants mais seulement 7 d'entre
eux seront lauréats dans chacune des
catégories présentées et les jeunes
réunionnais qui se lancent comme ici
d'en bas des cultures qu'on a un peu
oublié comme le vétiver et docks qui
font de la transformation des produits
pays et d'autres qui sont dans la
transformation numérique technologiques
écologiques et bien c'est la réunion qui
gagne et ça le département accompagne
ces personnes là tout simplement parce
que nous croyons que il y a encore des
possibilités d'un ciation l'insertion
par l'activité économique et soutenu par
le département de la réunion l'insertion
par l'activité c'est tout le parcours
entrepris par ses créateurs d'entreprise
tous fiers aujourd'hui de présenter le
travail réalisé
en fait tu me vois que dans l'entreprise
et c'est pas c'est là de la valeur et
que en train de monter un petit peu de
participants comme on dit et que mais
par contre nice est sur cette lancée là
en fait montré fier de mon parcours je
suis heureuse d'avoir été récompensé
parce que j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour
mettre en avant les produits de notre
patrimoine réunionnais je sens vraiment
un intérêt du département a récompensé
aussi les acteurs qui sont là pour faire
bouger le mouvement réunionnais alors
vraiment je suis très heureuse d'avoir
gagné ce challenge la 24e édition du
challenge des créateurs valorise une
nouvelle fois le savoir-faire
réunionnais vous pouvez retrouver tous
les portraits des candidats sur la page
facebook du département
[Musique]